c'est étonnant non
[Musique]
peut-on dissoudre la monarchie certes
nom s'écrit les royalistes fanatiques
hystérique à la solde des bourbons bien
sûr que si rétorquent les démocrates
congénitaux la sole de la république
alors qui croire qui croire direz vous
et bien une fois de plus c'est de la
rigueur de l'expérience scientifique que
jaillira la lumière pour réussir cette
expérience il suffit d'avoir sous la
main une bonbonnes d'acide sulfurique
une barrique et louis xiv anvers
lentement
l'acide sulfurique et on attend une
bonne seconde
[Musique]
eh bien oui le peuple a raison le 14 est
soluble dans l'acide sulfurique l'état
et mhi etonnant non
[Musique]
etonnant non